since launching legal proceedings
against the British government Gina
Miller has had to hire bodyguards the
investment fund manager has received
numerous death threats we met her at her
offices in one of West London's wealthy
districts we are about to go through
brexit which is such a momentous
decision we need people to speak up and
to talk about the scenarios on what will
be good or bad and come to the best
possible decision but all those people
are frightened no politician has been
willing to appear together with her in
public she tells us a search on the
internet quickly reveals some of the
hatred people have sent her away some
have even called for her a British
citizen to be deported and those are
amongst the least spiteful posts on
Twitter if I was a white man bringing
this case I possibly wouldn't have
experienced the same things because the
vitriol has been personally it's not
have really been about the case my life
has changed we don't really go out
anywhere anymore i don't use any public
transport anymore my children have
special school run you know a special
entrance at school so it has changed but
the publicity has also been useful for
gina miller when it comes to getting her
point across that her case is not about
preventing brexit but about a proper
debate on it and finally a vote in
parliament in my view that's what's
needed to talk about every element of
brexit what does it mean for agriculture
what does it mean for science what does
it mean for our schools what does it
mean for you know security I want the
parliamentarians to do their job to
deliver what's best for our country and
stand up for the people who elected them
not to do what's best for them and their
party before the referendum most MPs had
campaigned to remain in the EU but it is
expected that they would now vote in
favor of leaving even if it means a
so-called heart brexit after the vote
for brexit many parliamentarians had
hoped to influence the government and
keep the ties with Brussels as close as
possible but with Theresa May now
determined to leave the single market
this looks increasingly unlikely